mr. Sky News our top stories dis our
rail passengers are to receive automatic
refunds for late or council trains and a
new government plans and the health
watchdog 9 says doctors who hand out too
many antibiotics should be disciplined
my main story this morning Thai
authorities are hunting a suspect seen
on CCTV after at least 22 people were
killed in a Bangkok bomb attack
yesterday police say a small explosive
was thrown from a bridge in the center
of the city this morning without causing
any injuries Michelle covered reports
this was the moment when what is
believed to have been a pipe bomb
detonated outside one of Bangkok's most
popular shrines a mobile phone capturing
the sheer ferocity of the blast there
can be no doubt the attack was intended
to kill a maim on a mass scale and the
terrorists achieved their goal hitting
one of the busiest areas of the city
this is the worst incident that has ever
happened in the past there have been
some blasts and minor explosions but
this time they aim to take the lives of
innocent people
so what they want is to destroy our
tourism and our economy for whatever
reason compounding fear in Bangkok this
shocking moment after an unidentified
man threw an explosive device off a
bridge sending water cascading into the
air police say if it hadn't landed in
the water it would have caused injury
the search for that individual now added
to the hunt for this man who police say
is a suspect in the deadly bomb blast
picked up on CCTV near the Erawan shrine
he can be seen putting down a rucksack
and walking off the shrine attracted
thousands of Thais and foreigners every
day and the attack has inevitably
fractured confidence in a country which
relies so heavily on tourism
when we left Germany we did not think
about like anything like this could
happen here in Bangkok like in the city
centre we were thinking about not going
to Egypt not going to Morocco to
you just don't know where it's going to
come so I think personally it's just you
know being at the wrong place at the
wrong time and you just don't know
what's going to happen really there is
an urgency to the search for clues
initial thoughts were that Muslim
separatists in the South were the likely
bombers but no one has ruled out the
possibility of international terrorism
and that is drawn global concern and
cooperation foreigners are known to be
amongst the dead we are closely
monitoring the situation and our liaison
closely with local authorities to gather
information to determine whether any US
citizens were affected by the explosion
cannot say at this point that we know
that to be the case the British Embassy
in Bangkok is also liaison with the Thai
authorities and warning tourists to take
extra care and monitor news reports a
second bomb was found inside the Erawan
shrine and a suspect device located on a
nearby train line but forensic evidence
has not yet provided the critical clues
as to who was behind the deadly assault
Michelle Clifford Sky News well let's
bring in Alessandra ostrich who's a
journalist based in Bangkok joining us
via Skype as you see Alessandra welcome
to you a second explosion today much
smaller it goes without saying and no
injuries reported at least but it must
add to what must be a really tense
atmosphere in the city right now
absolutely yes the explosion had been
around three hours ago and under the
semantics Enbridge it is a small pier
where which is always very crowded with
people taking boats on the Champa River
the device originally was was thought to
be a grenade but five minutes ago the
Transport Minister said that actually
was another ie D it didn't cause any
injuries just because it fell into the
water
it was probably thrown by the bridge
which is also a pedestrian which people
can walk over it therefore yes it is
there was another explosion and luckily
you know produces take effect as
yesterday but people of course are very
tense actually as you say that in the
center looking at that footage you to
see that the impact is in the water
rather only the footbridge itself which
presumably means that it's you know
damaging effects have been minimized
which is one small nurse
are we talking here about a potential
campaign by the same group or could this
be a copycat attack launched by a group
looking to capitalize on the discomfort
and uncertainty faced by the government
right now I mean it's hard to tell isn't
it it is impossible to tell of course so
there is wide speculation in China and
everybody seems to have an idea on this
possible possible possible causes could
be internal political causes of course
Thailand has been under a military
regime for the past 15 months and among
the camp that lost to the military so
that the supporters of former prime
minister Thaksin Shinawatra's a lot of
discontent of course many people in
China but this is also due to the
existing prejudice and the stereotypes
say that this cannot be made by cannot
have been done by Thai people and
therefore they look at possible Muslim
responsibilities for example D that has
been an insurgency in time I'm going on
for over eleven years in the South that
has claimed six thousand casualties up
to now but they have never really
ventured far out of the those problems
India Malaysia another possible lead
could be the fact that a month ago
Thailand deported 109 who Eagers to
China so members of this discriminated
minority that came here to Thailand as
refugees but Thailand who is now getting
quite chummy with China sent them back
and that drew the ire of the widowed
diaspora who actually cause of violence
in stem from last month but all this
wide speculation of course at the moment
there is this footage that came out of
this man a young man dressed in a yellow
t-shirt with baggy pants that with an
unassuming presence that enter the
entered the compound of the Arab a
shrine yesterday three minutes before
the blast with a backpack on his back
and left soon after without a belly bag
having left the backpack on the ground
the images are very grainy so it's
difficult to identify the male but of
course everybody is talking about you
Bangkok and there is effectively a man
hand for what is the prime suspect of
this
attack yeah I mean you mentioned that
the Chinese who increasingly form such a
large proportion of the 25 million
foreigners who traveled to Thailand as
tourists each and every year the
government in Bangkok I mean they're
going to be really concerned that such
an important part of the economic mix
for Thailand is going to be in severe
jeopardy if this were to continue
they are extremely concerned tourism
especially Chinese tourism is what is
really keeping up the Thai economy so
far since the hunter took over last year
the economy has slowed down the latest
data asked he can talk about a growth of
under 1% of GDP the local currency had
pretty much collapsed in the past month
it lost almost 10 percent against the
dollar and the Chinese tourists arrival
arrivals have boomed in the past five
years they and basically upset me
decrease or let's say that the freeze of
the number of tourists coming from the
West
Thailand is getting gone especially
popular with Chinese tourists after a
popular movie called most in Thailand
that was an extremely extremely
successful comedy road movie in China
and they are Khmer drops many people of
course profit from that many people
complained about actually an even an
excessive presence of Chinese tourists
but overall Chinese tourists like other
Asian to is like Koreans and Japanese
are extreme extremely sensitive to
security issues and at the moment we
have five Chinese to is conferred upon
the dead there are others among the over
50 foreigners that have been injured and
therefore I'm pretty sure that in the
next months there's gonna be a huge
fallout fallout among the number of
Chinese tourists coming to China
Alessandra Osage thanks very much in the
few time today thanks a lot